I've actually had some close calls with
lithium batteries such as this one my
friend actually had an RC car and he
went to go charge his battery and they
suspected that the battery caused his
garage to literally burn down with the
Impala Myr batteries use a different
kind of electrolyte and they're
relatively lightweight makes them ideal
for gadgets like Jessi's Powell's
ill-fated RC car now that we're moving
on to our bigger batteries that could
release toxic fumes we have to wear
respirators safety first right guys this
is lithium polymer RC battery in three
two one
oh it's Rocking Oh God
oh my god stop
it's the proof they need that a lithium
based battery can ignite under pressure
and when you're on a roll hey let's try
this one
Oh what is that same as before lithium
polymer just bigger all right I look
scary it's around twice the voltage of
the battery that just went up in smoke
Valerie are you ready for this yes all
right
this is bigger lithium polymer in three
two one it looks like the muncher has
only succeeded in making another lithium
flapjack until my god
and you know the old saying where
there's smoke there's generally the
Fleur camera confirms that they've got
what they wanted
high-pressure combustion we got smart
smoke and even fire awesome for us but
not so great for our gardens man we also
found that the higher the voltage the
battery was that we got more explosive
results
the higher voltage creates a higher
current when shorted which generates a
higher temperature